whenever you get a question like this
it's always helpful to start working on
with these three results are or four or
five depend on how many what the degree
of your polynomial is it's always good
to work them at a start even if they
don't ask you to work them out like like
this question has the reason why is
because when you're doing these later
questions right these are always going
to be the building blocks that you use
to get to these okay and also suppose
for instance you look at one of them and
you know I know exactly which one of
these results only for instance for
instance suppose you go you're gonna
need these two okay you're like I don't
need this one it into where and if you
worry about it we're like it out okay
because the way these results work is by
taking the coefficients in order right
and also alternating the and the sign
and making sure you go back two pockets
on the easiest way to make sure that you
get all the results right is to actually
do all of the results in order it's
really hard to screw it up actually
figure Big C D - plus - if you do all of
them is quite simple okay where I see
people having trouble is when for
instance that they started this one the
can't remember if it's see on a the -
sing on it okay
whereas it's relatively easy to start
here because people remember that from
before giant formula or from your axis
of symmetry from the quadratic so
building it like this doing all three I
think or four or five is the easiest way
right so by now probably you've got York
results I think from Emory yeah okay so
when you have a look at the questions
some of them are very straightforward so
they require a little more tweaking okay
so for instance let's just do the first
one together because it's so simple how
do you send out you just asked to
evaluate all right so the first thing
you should do is just write it out
okay now there will usually be some kind
of simple factorization that you need in
this case because the first example is
just staring you in the face okay but
just to make it clear I will include
this line so that you know exactly what
things you're going to substitute in
okay and it also means that when I do my
next line if I have some problems with
it I get some error at the end I'll know
where the young where the issue was it
will just be like on my calculator okay
so what am I got here five by three
minus eight five five so that's 15 minus
40 that's minus the pause okay but when
you skip along down just say something
like Jade for starters there's some we
don't notation there this is a bit
sneaky because you may if you have a
look at F right what you see is this
okay the Sigma it is the question so
we're talking about this yesterday like
alphas and betas big Sigma is that it's
the closest the grease we've got to s
anyway so it's customarily what my
visitors use to signify a seulement
right so it's adding up a whole series
of things okay now the reason why it's
slightly sneaky is because later on in
term for when we do series and sequences
you will learn what we call Sigma
notation which is actually a very
specific way of using this and what it
means but here all you means is you can
say this often remember the sum of all
of these now what's this this is one
over one of the roots right so what it
means is whatever all of them and you
can actually see that written there in F
so when you look at G which says this
what would you guess that actually means
yeah that's right so he means absolute
and then the next root squared and then
the next root squared okay
now when you look at that maybe it jumps
out at you but if you like me it doesn't
you can see that obviously this must
have something to do with this okay
because where are you gonna get this
from if you start from either one of
these you're gonna have your alphas and
betas mixed up together and so I want
them to all be nicely separated okay so
I'm gonna have to start from here I've
got the necks of two right so I'm gonna
have to square make sure
so for my next line I would say note
that like I would actually write this so
that it's clear but this isn't actually
part of my main line working but I'm
trying to use what I get out of here
this result will be useful for me to
actually work out what this is if I take
that first result over there the summer
boots and a square it okay what am I
gonna get at the other end okay now if
you just expand this out here's what
you're gonna have you'll get alpha
squared V squared gamma squared which is
what we're after but then you get all
these um trailing extra terms expand it
properly I wrote it down to make sure
it's now because this expansion here has
the has the result I'm after
plus it's other stuff okay I want to
relate this to this so I'd say therefore
this result that on that right it's
equal to this take away all that other
rubbish okay so it's this result
- these guys trailing on the end okay
and that's all you need to do really but
I think the important thing is to have
this set up quite clear you can see why
I got this and how I got out of here
okay
so from this point now I can bring my
numbers in right this is just three
squared minus two lots of one so that's
what you get eight
no miss are you saying I'm doing one
okay so that makes it there so I think
the critical thing is most people would
they see this they start to do
essentially the same thing but it's not
set out in any way you just see a series
of equations and there's the
relationship that's clear between them
okay but worst is when you just see a
series of equal signs underneath each
other a sort of implying that they're
all the same thing but they're quite
emphatically not they're just trying I'm
using it as a useful result okay any
questions on that now we have a look at
the sheet you can see some of the
questions have asterisks on them they're
pretty they're pretty difficult
they're pretty messed up often they just
long okay so just be watchful for those
oh we could note that you actually need
if you see it goes down later opening
few RS at least if I thought it right
you need s before you do or yes before
you do so maybe you want to like stick
an arrow going from s do that before you
do or and also notice that for that
whole set after M see how it does hence
right so that's a clue that means if the
results you get from a to K they're all
going to be useful for you when you're
working at m2 s okay so once you've got
the numbers for say d e f g etc okay
they'll be really useful for eminent
onwards yeah okay it means it means s
for some right so this is kind of your
clue as to how it actually works out so
the sum of all the reciprocals of the
roots right that's what alpha minus 1
means it's 1 on alpha yeah
it's just it's just a shorthand way of
saying rather than writing out the whole
thing or what this whole thing okay
so we'll look I want to take every route
everyone individually square right so I
can wear everything that is the sum of
all the routes squared well I can't
rather tell everyone so for instance
well this is a pretty easy one okay so I
want all of the routes are powerful yeah
well okay what you think about it first
okay so for instance yes right
Foursquare Breda okay so what does this
mean this is taking two routes at a time
right but one of them we squared and one
is not right so the first one I'm
guessing will be alpha squared beta the
next one will be alpha beta squared
right I'm gonna get four more I like to
complete the set I'm gonna get let's see
here
meter squared gamma beta gamma squared
alpha squared gamma alpha gamma square
there are no other combinations that I
can make but do you see how all of these
fit the pattern of this I'm taking the
roots two at a time they're not both
squid they're just just one of them
right and that's why it matches up in
this way that make sense yeah okay like
I said it's kind of a weird way of
writing the notation I think he's just
you didn't want to write that's all and
also I mean the thing about this the
thing that's important the pattern is
visible here right so yeah that's why
he's real